hello and welcome to this video playing
just one guitar from Germany so what is
he up to we get a caesarean specially
golf ball slightly yeah yeah I'm playing
the slide against especially cough there
are some alternatives that white can go
for this is this is nine where a few
white hairs reasonably good control like
is also ok absolutely but there are no
fantastic things that way I can play
against especially [ __ ] my TM again I
feel this is a reasonably good line and
so what to do I both captures I mean sea
takes and cream cakes make sense I'm
going to do this I think like lucky sum
that should be ok here but i often feel
like you there still um it's still a
little something let's do let's check
this if i take this 658 probably and my
queen is is almost trapped
I wonder if f4 is an option sometimes a
king edge 1 and F form its this is a
plan that I have seen in some games
well against f four you can probably
just retreat the bishop and don't don't
react to them like don't capture not not
that this is necessarily bad to capture
it yeah I would seem you can play a 4
here of course this is not not easy
though if you play a four-year also we
can be for a little bit okay so f4 is
kind of the only move that make sense
here in connection with my previous
plane okay a membership f6 one thing is
if I'm go back 93 to d5 is now actually
becoming more of an option but it was
perform
he always has 90 for himself and this is
so this is a very very difficult
situation you around the D foursquare
whenever I move my knight he can sink
his night in to deform or here he also
has a green deform 95 down yeah I think
this is probably the way to initiate
some kind of fight I mean 95 is a real
for Khan Kareena non on Queen ad and
Bishop and he does not want me to take
on f6 probably and give him the double
porn I don't think this is something he
wants to want to allow 24 is an
interesting move here in this position
and i'm not i'm not totally sure what i
do now 95 is something that comes into
consideration I just got the April
that's really really a not easy not f5
is also move takes community group
cheeks and put pressure on d6 yeah I go
here this is just a just a gut feeling
decision I start the a foul him but some
other things are ok the knight on d5 is
also always having a look at the before
pawn yes the trade now I think otherwise
I go Queen f3 and that looks awkward or
to see maybe he has something else
entirely ok ok this kind of wolf ok
that's possible is his old form
and when I do for him
Oh
Oh interesting Jan not a happy move
absolutely not mm check I can take with
the bloody crew ah no Wow
ah that's terrible you can take away the
Queen
[Music]
and then 95 fantastic
I want a terrible game just got f3i
which is actually made maybe to all of a
sudden huh Queen Batum
damn difficult position
I take this night f to mate I'm morning
night f to mate actually crazy that's
crazy fantastic yeah those those kind of
coincidental things are always love I
can take the actually what am i doing it
quite resigned hmm that's really weird
ok so this this this this this and how
did I end up using this so quickly so
this one he choked check yeah okay can
take with the Queen something he can
just take with the Queen and then I have
no move I was actually not seeing that
so I have to do this and then this
position is this is on
yeah this is probably it's just a very
murky kind of position now the engine
says equal i would i would be i would
have been really shocked if I'm like
clearly viewers in this position that
that would be strange because I'm not so
badly coordinated to him but chat me
completely I didn't see that he has
screen takes f6 simply and this makes my
position absolutely awful and he played
very precisely everything was very
precise and here I'm just I'm just lost
again and i blundered g1 but it's just a
losing position yeah then so it's mostly
about one movie i am so here this is
kind of kind of normal kind of normal
looking ok now very tough right thanks
for watching